et le divorce hein non le divorce non
c'est chiant franchement c'est chiant
c'est long c'est cher parce que quand on
aime on compte pas mais quand on aime
plus
comment ça faire des tableaux Excel tu
sais alors ligne une table basse allez
viens c'est ça mais c'est notre faute le
divorce et notre faute quand je dis une
autre faute je parle de ma génération
pour qu'on divorce plus que les
générations précédentes parce que nous
on va trop bien nous on a répondu à tous
nos besoins primaires alors on commence
à se poser des questions superflues ça
je sais pas c'est un sagittaire je sais
pas
ascendant bélier va savoir ce qui me
réserve enfin c'est ça je te jure moi si
mon grand-père avait demandé à ma
grand-mère est-ce que tu m'aimes ma
grand-mère je sais pas là j'ai faim donc
si tu as du pain ouais je t'aime si tu
veux
sinon faut qu'on mange en fait je te
raconte qu'est-ce que tu me parles
d'amour mais tu es vraiment une
baltringue en fait toi qu'est-ce que tu
parles va chasser qu'est-ce que tu
racontes